I like throwing a curveball or two at
the beginning
um for both of you if uh look I'm a big
fan of both of your work and so but
there are going to be people out there
that have never seen anything you've
done before so if someone has never seen
anything you've done what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
oh in general yeah
oh dear
I I always want people to watch the the
thing I get the most pleasure from when
I run into strangers in the street
they're like oh I saw you in and I'm
like waiting for like what maybe maybe I
could film they saw me in
um that uh when people say they saw the
gift and I think it's
just because I like to think that um my
fingerprints were so all over that
Beyond just being an actor
um other than that I'd tell them to go
watch Warrior and um
have the assumption that I was actually
a real tough guy which I'm not
uh squirting
um
um gosh it's really hard sigourney's
just clicking through a hundred awesome
yeah exactly I want them to watch the
gorilla movie because they would learn
about conservation
oh yeah
I mean the gorillas are no longer on the
endangered lists but they will always be
endangered
so I mean that's unfortunately so many
creatures are
are under tremendous
stress and um and the and the human
world is not helping them at all
so I guess you know it's fun it's great
to be able to pursue this profession and
every now and then you get to do a movie
that has a you know a big
benefit yeah a big benefit
yeah I was curious what you were going
to say Sigourney because your resume is
um pardon my language [__] incredible
thank you thank you you know I'm still
yeah
believe me yes
yeah so if someone uh you guys have done
a lot of roles what do you think was
actually the most work you've done
before stepping on set for one of your
projects in terms of preparation as an
actor
wow I think for me it was Carrie I had
five years to work on it because we kept
being delayed
five years to sort of undo whoever I was
at that point and reconstitute my
13 14 year old so I didn't mean to work
on it that much it just turned out to be
a kind of lucky thing for me because by
the time I got to do it I was completely
over
what anything would be like to anybody
else but me that's clear
same two movies for me the gift because
you know I wrote it and I was thinking
about it constantly and
rewriting it for five years but but the
hardest work as an actor would is
Warrior because we were just some things
I think you can turn up and fake
um there is the physical aspects of that
we were we really just needed to get
there early and I think it was three
three months early
and every day all day training and
getting the skills for that
Sigourney I did love your work in Avatar
too you're the character you played I
couldn't believe how you channeled being
a teenager uh my last thing it's an
individual question for you Sigourney
before getting into this film I love
Galaxy Quest I want to stress the word
love
um and I'm just curious when did you
realize that that it it meant a lot to
so many people
I almost said I'd want to see Galaxy
Quest first instead a girl is in the
Mist because that is the way I really
felt in outer space like a blonde who
doesn't really know how to do anything
and um so for me to play this character
who could figure everything out and know
what buttons to push and do this and use
a flamethrower and all this stuff that
was acting man I really am Gwen and um
and I love that the movie is a love
letter to All actors who go off and do
these crazy stories
I I cannot recommend that film enough to
anyone who has not seen it it's
incredible
um jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys today I know you both read a lot of
scripts and I'm sure there's a lot of
filmmakers that want to work with you
what was it about this project that said
oh I need to do this
hey it was Paul uh
uh you know getting getting the phone
call from a guy like Paul to be one of
his Leading Men uh after having really
really been obsessed by first performed
in particular in his recent
filmography
um
and then writing the script with real
nervous uh fearful kind of like um you
know hoping that what I'm reading is
enticing enough and exciting enough and
um
and it was um you know in and I
for all the films I've watched I've
never read his scram place which was a
real pleasure because they're not
they're incredibly different I mean they
still look the same and they're
generally it's a screenplay but there's
an elegance and an efficiency
um and it kind of a
um
reluctance to overly explain histories
of characters
flashes of understanding of the past but
no like
you know no abundance of exposition and
in the exposition that's there is very
elegantly sort of placed and very
artfully placed
um so yeah I mean script plus Paul
it was uh a real honor I think you know
something I feel
I remember thinking at someone because
it was during Cove it was like
does he really want to know
like sent all and he's accidentally
called the wrong person
[Laughter]
I feel like that every movie to be
honest
ly
well I was sent the script and I was so
surprised to be offered a Paul Schrader
script which you know he has he's known
for such very uh powerful
um male characters and I
I really felt that you know in in in
Taxi Driver he has these two incredible
women in it and that this in an odd way
was a revisiting of these two different
characters very different but the the
fact that he that the male character was
going back and forth between these in a
kind of triangle
um I thought it was such an arresting
script so beautifully written so elegant
and the idea of working with bull
Schroeder you know who's one of our
great master filmmakers I met him the
next day I think
um
and I completely forgot to phone on him
and tell him how much I admired him and
how much I like this and that I just
went straight to like what about this
what about that what about this and I I
realized later that I should fond on him
a little bit but I was so excited I just
wanted to get to talking about the
script
I was gonna say it worked out
um speaking of fawning um Joel I'm just
curious when you're working with someone
like Sigourney how many days into the
shoot before you started geeking out
over the ice storm or Ghostbusters or
alien or 50 other projects that uh
Sigourney has done I like to keep a lot
of this inside
um and now dangerously it's bubbling to
the surface is he talking right now we
you know we've worked together before we
worked on Exodus with Ridley yeah so we
had a bit of a chance you know we were
playing his mother yeah and he had a
very wonderful part in that a very
complex complex person that was cut down
to being kind of a villainous person but
we also you know we we got to ride
around in a golf cart in um in London at
the studios and stuff so we've I've done
a bit of fawning but there's a lot more
fawning I could do this morning
I was thrilled to be doing this with
Joel
no you you got oh
I was gonna say you guys are also great
together
um one of the things I really enjoyed
was Andrew's cinematography I I like the
Simplicity of where the camera is placed
and it's sort of like um with Paul
there's not a not a nothing unnecessary
it's just very to the point you know uh
can you sort of talk about that aspect
you I'm probably interrupting a question
you're leading to but that you really
nailed it and I don't know if you've
read stuff that he said about this but I
remember
um being really impressed by the the
design cinematography and the design of
first reformed and I being on set with
Paul I realized what he does and
hopefully I'm not giving away a trick
but other people should use it anyway is
that he looks at the set and he takes
away anything that's unnecessary for the
scene
so that there's these sets that are
populated by the actors
um and the chair that they need to sit
on and maybe a certain prop but
everything else sort of systematically
Stripped Away until it feels like
only what's necessary is there and I
think that says a lot about not just
this the set but the way he approaches
uh his writing and the way he shoots and
even the way he talks to actors it's
it's always
um
concise
I was also going to say something about
Paul is that he's he seems to love
making telling stories about someone
with a a dark past hiding behind like a
a day job who eventually has to explore
something that they are uncomfortable
exploring you know he he tends a lot of
these stories did he ever tell you what
his fascination with these kind of
characters are
well I feel like it's sort of been a
thing for him forever
um
looking to really good question to ask
Paul actually
where he sees the the
the repetition of that
you know because he is he is playing
variations on a song all of the time
um but but you know in Master Gardener
it seems like and I think he you know to
relatively quote Paul from the other
night talking about
you know that in his early days he was
desperate to tell the world [__] you and
that in this film he's starting to move
towards telling the world I love you and
and and I think there's a softening in
this film albeit it still carries the
marks of everything you're talking about
this is sort of
contrast of Worlds of violence versus
sort of a new peaceful future and
um the the day job versus the kind of
razor sharp Violet so the yeah I'm
really curious about that too if you
find out the answer could you let me
know and I'm going to ask him on Friday
yeah
I I I'll definitely I'll text you no I
won't text you
for both of you I love learning about
the behind the scenes the making of
movies television so for soon to be fans
of the film is there anything that you
think might surprise them about the
making of the film
oh I'll tell you a couple of things I
mean just quickly lose shot much faster
than you would think 20 days
um
Paul was wearing an eye patch uh the
entire time because in the window he had
to shoot it he realized that he had to
put off an eye surgery that was
necessary so he looked like John Ford
um just kind of directing you know uh
you know he he was a little unwell you
know during that time but I've never
seen anyone shoot a 20-day shoot and
usually it's it for you know a young
filmmaker
and and the energy is like you're being
chased down the street by a bear like
there's no time for anything and
everybody's panicking I've never seen
someone shoot a movie in 20 days and be
so calm about it you didn't yeah because
he he wasn't he wasn't feeling that well
I think there was no extra energy for
any drama for any long conversation
luckily Alexander has worked with him
before so there was a spareness to the
way they had a thing you know they they
kind of must have talked a lot but I
mean he really he brought every
discipline with him when he was
directing the editing the writing the
cinematography all you know he he can do
everything and so I think only someone
like that could shoot this movie that
fast when he wasn't feeling his best and
did you notice his cameo in the film no
I actually didn't notice the Cameo is he
a white supremacist no he's in the film
well I I don't know for certain whether
he he put it he'd put himself in the cut
but he did play in the scene in the um
uh the ni or Alcoholics Anonymous I uh
moment uh I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
find out if he's still in there but if
he is that's his Alfred Hitchcock moment
I I didn't notice that
um I'll be I didn't notice it I I uh um
I'm out of time with you guys but can I
ask just one last question
um I'm not sure if they're gonna kick it
yeah I'm gonna tell you right um it's
actually it's an individual question for
both of you um Joel I'm actually really
excited for dark matter because of what
it's about and the whole alternate
reality Multiverse kind of thing I
wanted to know if you could just tease
people what it's about and Sigourney I
have to ask you uh they're filming a
certain Ghostbusters sequel right now
and is there any chance that you could
be popping up in it
God damn I do that I'm origin now in
that time ten percent I play Slimer is
another
uh doc doc matter is
um very sliding doors as the quickest
possible reference and and the quest it
raises these amazing questions about the
life you didn't choose to live and if
you had the chance of doing it would you
covet that take it over
um and to tease something else for
anyone uh apart from my mother who's a
fan of mine
towards the end of the series I think I
played
25 plus versions of the same person wow
so if you if you're not a fan of mine
don't watch it is going to be over
saturated yeah yeah wow yeah the thing
the thing that I I've always thought
about is you know you get offered to to
move like you get offered a job in Paris
and if you take that your life could
radically change or if you don't go and
we're all we always have these choices
and I think the series deals with that
um which I find fascinating yeah that's
what I try
yeah I like how Sigourney didn't answer
my question but I I'll take it no I mean
I I listen I um
I've been very busy but no one uh you
know I wasn't asked to be in this
Ghostbusters and um I think you know a
little of us goes a long way yes well
you know they're not supposed to call
you you're supposed to call them right
that's what the song says who are you
gonna call right listen I want to thank
you so much for giving me extra time and
also congrats on the movie I thought you
guys did such a great job with it and um
you know thank you for giving me your
time oh man thank you good to see you